we welcome you back to cbs mornings it
was one year ago today that the last
american troops left afghanistan ending
a 20-year war the longest in u.s history
we all remember the scene there was
mayhem in the weeks before the final
pull-out is tens of thousands of afghans
at kabul's airport tried to flee mts
thai mts tayab returned to kabul
recently and spoke with a former afghan
interpreter for the u.s air force who is
still unable to leave and says he fears
for his life
the final image of the last u.s service
member leaving afghanistan taken at the
stroke of midnight one year ago
the chaos that has marked the end of
america's longest war has come to define
president biden's botched withdrawal
following the taliban's rapid takeover
triggering the collapse of the u.s
backed government and national army
sending tens of thousands of terrified
afghans to kabul's main airport begging
to be airlifted to safety even passing
their young children to soldiers hoping
at least they would be saved
a suicide bombing in the crowd carried
out by the afghan affiliate of isis
killed nearly 200 including 13 u.s
service members one year later and it's
quiet here
all that's left to remind us of the
horrors are fragments of people's
clothes caught in this razor wire
thousands of desperate afghans came to
this gate the abbey gate in order to
flee the taliban and get on one of those
u.s military aircraft out of the country
but many more were left behind
including former interpreter syed
morteza wafa
we're in a safe house right now sure
we filmed on smartphones so as not to
draw the taliban's attention to his
location
they always call me american spy they're
still searching for me to find me
why do they call you an american spy
because i was a translator for three
years for the u.s air forces and i was
very close to the united states air
forces wafa was based at the bagram
airfield which was the largest u.s
military base in afghanistan retired
master sergeant with the air force david
piscorick is desperate to get waffa out
do you believe his life is in danger i
do he's always been a very truthful
individual
especially while we were you know
working side by side and hand in hand
i have no no reason to doubt whether or
not he's in danger it's unknown exactly
how many afghan translators remain
trapped in afghanistan according to the
u.s government 17 000 afghans including
wafa have submitted applications for
what's known as special immigration
visas while another 74 000 are still
working their way through the highly
complex submission process
for waffa one year on too little is
being done to improve things
if you could ask
president joe biden one question what
would it be
help the translator to get in safety
we helped americans
so why he cannot
help
all those transla translators who left
behind in here
in a very hard situation
the u.s government has said it's trying
to streamline the visa process but for
far too many afghans still living in
fear of the taliban it's not happening
fast enough for cbs mornings in this tag
kabul afghanistan